[Music]
three two one action welcome back to
off-the-record where we talk about what
what I want to talk about is Joe how is
your vegan diet going I broke that [ __ ]
a long time ago homie
I mean watermelon you got watermelon on
your shirt to wear yeah I don't even
fall down I don't even see it my glasses
on they just don't there's no man we'll
talk about Spades in ten minutes but
everyone wearing green right now oh yeah
you got every woods right like a [ __ ]
agreement you know is it weird how
whoever sitting on the sides like we
always kind of match kind of outsides
are you talking about
each side the table side of the table
he's two people Hangul each side yeah oh
so I had an eczema attack right I don't
even know if I talked about this but no
it was a time that you had yours yeah
kind of right after it was all over my
body from neck to toe I didn't know what
the [ __ ] to do man so I started
researching because I've been dealing
with this all my life
same with you right you've been [ __ ]
dealing with it I did exactly what
you've been doing like years ago because
I had a really big outbreak like after
we does the Salton Sea shoot for like a
just for some reason after that day like
my face was all crusty and my kitchy and
red and stuff oh my god your face gets
it - yeah my face gets it so it's like
today when I was like I need to find
some Pharma [ __ ] and like and like just
fix it he's like if you went have you
ever had it that bad before on before
that time no and that's when I had to
like just do a lot of research but then
after a while I'm like hey I now I have
it under control with my injections and
stuff I want to do it like naturally -
because I don't want to like rely on it
all the time just like to put in your
stomach yeah it's like right here you
have the pincher fan
and gather a little bit of it and just
inject into the fact cuz like this
absorbs that yes yeah yeah it's kinda
like steroids I guess I don't know but I
rather take steroids but there is a way
to get rid of eczema naturally but it's
it's a lifestyle commitment and that's
what it's like I [ __ ] wish I knew
this cuz this was the biggest outbreak
I've ever had since childhood I never
had it from head to toe like in my adult
years what caused it
I'm thinking it's diet and I went down
the rabbit hole and I did my own
research and again like I'm not a doctor
so I should have got to the hospital but
you carry now there's coving they
wouldn't even have seen you or like a
private private allergist or whatever
mythologized you care the pretty nicely
right now
but here's the thing though I know what
they're gonna do okay like standard
protocol for eczema is they're gonna
give you steroid cream and they're just
gonna tell you chill right like what
when you had your outbreak what did they
give you steroid cream and [ __ ]
gloves right my hands healed though
which is awesome
it is good but here's the thing though
there's a high probability that your
skin becomes addicted to the cream and
steroid cream because was shaking and
like right no more [ __ ] is it because
they don't teach you lifestyle change
where you have to fix it internally and
so that's why most people will go it'll
get worse they don't know what's going
on but they don't change what they eat
with eczema you know what eczema
it's called atopic dermatitis or
whatever right but basically what it is
is just have you got a psoriasis yeah
it's similar to that where there's a you
just get a breakout and your skin just
[ __ ] goes nuts and it's itching like
crazy it might turn into little blisters
that like pop afterwards it's like
hurting you you still scratching any
tears yeah it feels like is in the birds
at the same time yeah yeah it feels like
little needles on your skin but then
there's times when it burns and there's
times when it just itches and you just
want to scratch and it feels good to
scratch this is scratching meteors
it does but
that's how it works in that way and it's
already like sensitive frog I was
telling Casey like it's scratching
eczema feels better than the jamming on
no you gotta scratch it feels so Bob
when it comes in these stages right and
meat like so first your skin's not bad
but it's it itches like crazy so you
itch it and then the skin flares up
right so when it flares up it might even
turn into little blisters or whatever
depending on how bad it is and then it
makes it wanna you want to scratch it
even more then the skin breaks then your
skin gets weaker and then it cracks and
because of that it's a susceptible
infection or whatever so it's this
non-stop cycle of [ __ ] scratching and
destroying your skin like your skin is
like eating itself and just like
deteriorating and there's nothing you
could do about it but scratch it gets so
bad sometimes where I'm like okay I
can't scratch it no more it's like so
[ __ ] already so I start slapping you
because if that feels [ __ ] really
good oh yeah something man just [ __ ]
something it's sucks because the the way
you heal from it is not scratching it
but you're like a crack head that just
starts [ __ ] going like this all day
long it's like God's playing tricks on
you I know dude the only way for it to
feel good is to scratch it buddy not
supposed to scratch the [ __ ] and my
nephew has a bad - every time we're
talking he's just sitting there going
[Laughter]
and now like me when I was a kid you
know and I think like it sucks cuz you
forget how it feels until it comes back
yeah sure is it only I mean obviously
it's not by like is it a lot of Asians I
get it I've known had it more Asian it
runs in my family
I don't have it my little sister has it
I don't like a lolly like half my
Filipino friends have it yes I have a
lot of Filipino friends I have it too
though yeah they were saying that this
year or I think Barr was mentioning how
there's been a rise in eczema outbreaks
in Asians specifically high so I think
it's just you know our skins different
and we might have acclimated to a more
humid
climate and our diet is different in 8rr
as in like our ancestors diet variations
is different dairy products as if there
is a huge thing so a lot of us our
eczema outbreak comes out from dairy
because we can't process so most
cultures like that didn't have the dairy
like the cow or whatever like typically
after childhood you lose the enzymes to
break down the dairy but then like
European culture Middle Eastern culture
that has milk in the diet like non-stop
till adulthood uh yours you still have
the enzyme to break it down yeah it's
it's kind of like cultural science or
whatever we should go back to our
country I know you made the diets
correct dude do you feel more relaxed
okay well here's the thing this is the
thing that [ __ ] blew my mind right I
wish I knew this information I wish I
experimented and I had YouTube back then
cuz it was the biggest flare-up but it
also was the fastest recovery that I had
it took me no more than three days for
the flare-up to all kind of disappear
and start to heal it took me a week to
completely smoothen out and now it's
almost like I had nothing and I have
pictures Wow you went up to my [ __ ]
wrists so that does two weeks now a
Rolex yeah and now there's just kind of
like scars kind of you know how you got
the eczema scars your skin's thin do you
have sunspots to where you had a ex-mla
I guess sunspots on my hands yeah does
it feel like chickenpox did you have
chicken pox I had chicken pox it's just
as bad as it could get pretty bad where
you just itch all over a tip it just
depends on how bad your what do you call
the symptoms are some people is like
crazy some people it's just kind of like
here and that's what I had for most of
my adult years is just kind of itchy
here and then Casey I would look at him
like damn I remember what that was like
I'm so bad I couldn't close my hand like
goes a cracker work with cameras and
stuff ever I couldn't really hold the
camera spin so [ __ ] tight it's just
like hard it's like like dry dry and
scaly and like yeah they're just like
the fluidity of your
if you're like skin in the moisture and
elasticity is gone now I'm sue of a
[ __ ] like this and then that when you
do that it's just cracking so when you
go like a humid environment there's a
few like oh dude yeah it's like it goes
away the moment I go to like Asia or
Hawaii Florida is like it's gone they
don't wanna come back here if you go to
Vegas oh my god it's [ __ ] worse yeah
oh [ __ ] there's kind of and for seasonal
to like when it's cold mine disappears
yeah it's true yeah you could be cold or
worse seasons changing right then the
dryer when it's cold yeah I thought it'd
be like dry it could be a dry thing but
I think it's an inflammation thing cuz
you didn't know so like when your body's
hot or like whatever and it's it's
easier to enflame right so like when I
went down this rabbit hole of trying to
figure out how to cure myself from this
and I also talked to my cousin who's
like into holistic healing and all this
stuff right and so he put me on his
regimen and I did my own thing and what
I figured out is that this is my
suspicion right I did a pretty hard game
like within a little over a month I did
like almost 10 pounds of muscle or
something like that right I ate like mad
protein and so I wasn't probably eating
enough fiber and vegetables and other
things and and so what happens to the
body is when you consume only protein
all of a sudden is it overworked your
liver and kidneys and then so proteins
not a bad thing has to be done I guess
and everything had to do with graduals
right yeah you can't just automatically
do it so that wasn't really the problem
though the problem came when your body's
overworked and then you go alright I'm
gonna take a break cuz you know how we
all do this where we're like I'm gonna
take a break for my diet I'm gonna eat
whatever I want for a week I'm gonna
chill I'm not gonna work out and then I
just went ham on the junk food and the
dairy I had ice cream every day and I'm
allergic to dairy and you need a break
speaking of breaks oh yeah and now it's
time for a break from our sponsor shout
outs to oxy Queen and I personally love
this product as you guys know I train
all the time and I also get bloody noses
almost every time I train I get popped
in the face
if I get choked out I don't know why my
blood squirts out and you guys all seen
it and what I love about OxiClean it's
really one of the only cleaners that I
know that can help get blood out so it
saves a lot of my clothes and so we have
one in our laundry room and every time I
come back from training whether it's on
my wraps or my t-shirt ever I spray it
and it gets out so OxiClean is a
convenient laundry stain remover that
tackles the toughest dried end stains
with five types of stayin fighters
remove grease oil grass blood the soil
clay food and drink stains the first
time it tackles the toughest dried in
stains with five types of powerful stain
fighters and it binds to dirt and soil
to suspend them and then rinse them away
and it's safe on colors which is awesome
compared to bleach spray now and wash up
to seven days later so you got a try
OxiClean maxxforce for yourself to work
your magic with OxiClean go to OxiClean
comm slash max force one to get a coupon
for one dollar off so go work your magic
with OxiClean go ahead man OxiClean comm
slash max force one to get that one
dollar off baby okay man I'm gonna use
that link I just ran out over ill I just
straight-up ran out this week maybe you
should have done this dude to do use the
powder or use the spray it spray yeah
yeah yeah cuz yeah my dog always throws
up all over the place all the time
yeah stomach problems yeah I use it all
the time you can't put that like on the
eczema and hope it goes away
OxiClean try it probably a bad idea
probably a bad idea yeah well uh what
yeah so what happened was I just started
itching on my legs a little bit and then
on Saturday me and bar we go to shoot
right see some McDonald's we're just
even regular whatever by the time I get
home my whole body's itchy and I'm just
in bed just like oh right you also had a
quesadilla collection I had a quesadilla
all the cheese and that was the
cheeseburgers that
I want that quesadilla - yeah but I paid
for it the next day I was just bedridden
and man it was crazy
explain how you got it we got rid of it
so fast all right so so I did the
research yeah and I'm just assuming that
it's inflammation from overworked like
just internals right I had to do a flush
and I was like okay I hear people doing
these like cleanses and cleaning out the
liver or kidneys or whatever I'm like
how do they do this
and then so my cousin's like all right
start off in the morning
you get 20 ounces of water go grab some
lemons I'm like hell yeah I got a lemon
tree bro let's squeeze that [ __ ] [ __ ]
in there thirty minutes later you chill
you juice a bunch a kale that's about 16
to 20 ounces I mean Matt Cail um celery
right so it's just celery juice and then
you chug that thing and I [ __ ] you not
man I [ __ ] had Mad Dog it was crazy
[ __ ] you know yeah and then I also
combine that with intermittent fasting
because that's something I put in
because I know with intermittent fasting
it gives your body a break to stop
working your digestive system for a
minute and your body kind of needs that
in order to kind of clean things out so
the whole goal was to kind of [ __ ] do
a whole oil change right here and then
from there I introduced just all
plant-based for three days straight and
that was really hard to do cuz I think
I'm addicted to protein for sure you see
that changes like drastically per day
like Mikey goes away
yeah it's it's kind of crazy how fast it
worked
it was I would say it was two days of
painful confusion and then as the like
the flush process happened it was like
every day got progressively better while
the thing was still there but then you
can feel it oh and I did a hot ass bath
so like just once or every single day
what's the hot bath for cuz my body was
itching so [ __ ] much I couldn't
take it anymore I went to work out and
in even when I'm working out like I'm
walking and my legs just feel like pain
Oh burning right yeah so then like I'm
like trying to do a pull-up and in like
I'm like right so I just said [ __ ] this
[ __ ] I'm just gonna burn off all of this
pain and I just turned it on oh I took a
hot ass bath and it hurt but then
afterwards it felt good like you get out
it's it's kind of like a massage where
it's painful and then the advisory
relaxed option yeah cuz you get out but
as naked right I'm still wet so then
like the ACS on me and [ __ ] and I feel
like a breeze so I'm like oh that felt
frickin good but yeah I don't know man I
was just doing whatever I could for like
three days straight I couldn't get
anything done
was it hard to go via uh I don't know is
it vegan yeah I just went all vegetables
no animal product right like no but I
didn't do any sauce eggs yeah and I cut
out caffeine no coffee on that you did
it really yeah cuz I just want it to
heal so I was like alright fruits and
veggies I didn't know what else to eat
have to try the barbell for good
performance greens or anything yet BBQ
calm but I also need the immunity
booster because we also need the immune
system was funny the pre-workout to work
out yeah that's maybe that would've gave
me that energy add a couple of headbands
cuz if you're sweating you gotta throw
this fight and we would have had brunch
I know you can buy a shirt and they cut
it and the buy another shirt to wear and
then cut that part and put that over oh
you know fit though I you didn't try it
out what's wrong prove me wrong
Imran I don't think taking a hot bath is
like properly yeah I think that's good
food probably would but you're desperate
easy uh I think why does your the throne
that you were naked
cuz it feels good to be naked up in the
ACE because you oh yeah he was naked
like Pilate on the couches then they see
black touch him everywhere
I wasn't even I could even
laid out because it [ __ ] itch I
actually think that the heat like numbed
it oh when I started taking the bath for
example it would each every hour - right
after the bath I would go for like four
to five hours of no itch I know that
feeling that one I got eczema and what
so mine was a specific one it's called
dizzy hydrosis and it was only on like a
palms palm type skin so I don't get it
here anything is just only on my hands
and my feet and the parts that are on my
feet it's so much that when I would like
walk on top of sidewalk that's been
baking in the Sun and it's [ __ ] hot
but it actually feels good yeah and
you're like oh it feels like you're
[ __ ] fury and jacked off yeah
actually the burn does get to you it
actually feels like just real burn now
so you think the run away but every now
and then when you step on it and you
feel them like it feels like the burn of
the sidewalk is burning the burn of the
feet and it feels good yeah it's weird
surfaces only on the palms and the
bottom of your feet yeah I think mine
was just so my doctor was explaining to
me like lean back I was asking about the
humidity yeah he's like I don't do a
good job of moisturizing with lotion and
stuff so with with us getting the pool
that means swimming like every single
day and then also not taking a shower
after like that was my shower so I had
constant chemicals on my body so I think
it destroyed my moisture reserves and
that's when this part I started popping
out I've been trying to do so much
better about like taking care of my skin
like getting actual moisturizer thank
you got it yeah what's with guys you
don't you're taught not to put that not
talked not manly or not lucky others I
feel like now it's like canard wanted
care of it I want to look good I want to
like actually like not to deal with some
of the [ __ ] that I do it so I'd be like
trying to like yeah your guys your
guys's bodies produce the wildest [ __ ]
at least like with Bart I'm like how the
[ __ ] did that come out of there like how
does that happen
shits or something everything like
there's just the weird it like this year
for him has been like so wild crazy
Jenna worse dude like you almost went
deaf in one year cuz you had ear boogers
he just had a
cannot like his [ __ ] deaf ear this year
at [ __ ] eczema for the first time in
my life this year what else you're just
your whole body's jacked up you don't
bite the mosquito why's that [ __ ] get
him flame like crazy mad before you look
like Popeye [ __ ] yeah it's like this
year's been the craziest for my body I
don't know what else do you man I do I
do notice like as we get older as I'm
getting older I'm like I smell a lot
more like my body is starting to produce
a lot more odors really just like
naturally yeah like my armpits think a
lot more if I don't cases like yeah only
been like five days since I showered but
I don't understand what I'm telling so
bad honestly no yeah I feel like like in
college I could go five days and I'm
like man you smell that bad you know
maybe you're smelling is getting better
smelling Damon tip had to tell you that
you smell probably state if you smelled
maybe I should take it back I'm like oh
yeah I started smelling one the moment I
met - yeah she told me yeah
[Music]